die bundeskanzlerin hat gesagt beim
klimaschutz dürfe es kein pille palle
mehr geben
jetzt liegt ein paket zum klimaschutz
vor dass mehr als 54 milliarden euro
kosten soll
die einen sprechen trotzdem von
pillepalle die anderen sagen wer soll
das alles bezahlen zumal die wirtschaft
gerade in diesem moment wohl in eine
rezession rutscht was das alles für uns
bedeutet diskutiere ich jetzt mit meinen
beiden gästen sahra wagenknecht und
christian lindner in unter den linden
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zur unter den linden
schön dass sie dabei sind herzlich
willkommen bei den beiden gästen sahra
wagenknecht fraktionsvorsitzende die
linke
man muss hinzufügen noch sie haben
angekündigt dass sie nicht wieder
kandidieren werden jetzt im herbst und
christian lindner ebenfalls
fraktionsvorsitzender und parteichef der
fdp herzlichen herzlich willkommen in
beiden hierbei unter den linden
vielen dank ich bin gespannt mit fdp und
der linken heute am tisch ob er
irgendwelche gemeinsamkeiten überhaupt
finden bei der wirtschaftspolitik ist
sicherlich schwierig beim klimaschutz
gibt es so etwas gemeinsam mir fällt
wollen wir beide schützen
und ich glaube wir finden beide nicht so
toll was die koalition beschlossen hat
wenn auch vielleicht aus
unterschiedlichen gründen das wäre der
punkt der mir als erstes eingefallen
wäre und dem er auf jeden fall heute
vertiefen wollen und ich finde es
spannend man weiß ja von den grünen was
die vom klimaschutz halten wie da die
linie ist von der bundesregierung
inzwischen auch sowohl fdp als auch
linke haben das ja nicht immer
markenkern unbedingt gehabt was wäre
denn für die linke zum beispiel was ist
der klimaschutz im schnitt
klimaschutzpolitik kurz zusammengefasst
bei der partei die linke also wir meinen
dass wir vor allem darüber reden müssen
wie wir produzieren was wir produzieren
und dass es nicht angeht dass man die
großen klimasünder und das sind vor
allem die großen unternehmen die großen
konzerne dass man die außen vor lässt
und am ende die kleinen leute die
mittelschicht belastet und genau darauf
läuft dieses klima paket der koalition
hinaus und vor allem sind wir der
meinung es muss um alternativen gerungen
werden also jemand der auto fährt und
pendelt und auf dem land wohnt der macht
das nicht in der regel weil er das auto
so toll findet sondern weil er einfach
kein bus fährt und die bahn stillgelegt
wurde
und darum muss ich meines erachtens und
unseres erachtens die politik kümmern
und für die fdp
am letzten punkt will ich anknüpfen in
der tat wir wollen eine freiheitliche
lebensweise erhalten
dazu gehört auch die wahlfreiheit bei
der mobilität gibt leute die mögen sogar
das auto
frau wagenknecht ist auch eine
schlüsselindustrie mit hunderttausenden
beschäftigten die milliarden steuern
zahlt und deshalb steht für uns im
zentrum wir wollen gerne den
erfindergeist in deutschland
mobilisieren wir sind doch eine
ingenieur nation
also müssen wir die technologien
entwickeln die eine freiheitliche
lebensweise und wirtschaftlichen
fortschritt vereinbar machen mit
klimaschutz und auch ansonsten
ökologischer sensibilität und ich sehe
darin auch eine hohe moralische aufgabe
für deutschland denn auf dem weg
verzicht auf wohlstand werden uns viele
auf der welt nicht folgen können weil
sie gar keinen wohlstand haben
also müssen wir einen weg finden wie
wirtschaftliche prosperität und freiheit
mit dem klima vereinbar werden
bei ihnen war es also klimaschutz mit
dem sozialen zusammenzubringen trotzdem
habe ich so das gefühl die linke wird er
in deutschland nicht als erste partei
und nicht als zweiter partei genannt
wenn es um klimaschutz geht fehlt der in
ihrer partei die kompetenz oder einzelne
politiker die sich immer schon diesem
thema angenommen haben die sich um
dieses thema kümmern also sicher müssen
wir darüber nachdenken warum wir nicht
so wahrgenommen werden aber natürlich
haben wir konzepte und es ist ja nicht
so dass der sich um den klimaschutz am
meisten verdient macht der am meisten
davon redet also ich finde zum beispiel
die aktuell diskutierten konzepte wo man
sich über bietet wie hoch der co2 preis
sein soll was am ende darauf hinausläuft
dass sagen sie dann nicht so gern dazu
dass heizöl teurer wird das benzin
teurer wird ohne dass die leute oft
alternativen haben dass man sich damit
um den klimaschutz verdient macht wenn
man da also sozusagen die preistreiber
spirale anheizt während umgekehrt ist
zum beispiel sie haben recht viele leute
auf dem land mögen auch die mobilität
aber für viele pendler ist das auto
nicht unbedingt sehr attraktiv weil die
stehen im stau ist stress wenn wir eine
attraktive verbindung hätten die dann
eben über bahn oder bus oder anderweitig
zur verfügung steht dann würden sie das
sicherlich nutzen
aber es gibt solche verbindungen ich und
in einem punkt allerdings möchte ich an
den er ausdrücklich zustimmen ich finde
auch und das finde ich ist ein riesiges
versagen auch der politik aber auch der
unternehmen wollen die großen
unternehmen das wir natürlich viel mehr
investieren müssen in die erforschung
neuer technologien und wenn ich dann
höre dass autokonzern zum beispiel der
chef von vw sagt auch
technologieoffenheit brauchen wir gar
nicht wir reden jetzt mal der mode
hinterher
pro mobilität obwohl es ganz andere
sinnvolle ideen gibt wasserstoff
brennstoffzelle andere treibstoffe und
es wird alles jahr frauchen das finde
ich ein riesiges versagen in diesem land
weil wir so unsere zukunft wirklich
verspielen ich bin ganz der meinung von
ihr haben wir werden den besonderen
moment wo ich immer mal wieder einmal
festhalten
ok damit eigentlich war der ja weil ich
finde absolut fast frau wagenknecht sagt
wird nur also hinsichtlich der
technologie offenheit und dass bestimmte
unternehmen da auch sehr einseitig
agieren und das halte ich in doppelter
hinsicht für falsch erstens wir werden
die klimaziele nur erreichen können wenn
wir auch die bestehende fahrzeugflotte
klimaneutral machen und das geht mit
sogenannten synthetischen kraftstoffen
die aus co2 gewonnen werden braucht man
kein neues auto sondern auch ihr was
weiß ich 1984 golf kann klimaneutral
werden in einem anderen kraftstoff das
gleiche gilt übrigens für ölheizungen
auch da eine frage des brennstoffs aber
es ist nicht allein ein versagen der
wirtschaft sondern es sind die
politischen rahmenbedingungen denn diese
bundesregierung hat zugestimmt dass
diese synthetische kraftstoffe nicht auf
die co2 flotten verbräuche angerechnet
werden
das benzin das gewonnen wird aus
fossilem öl von den saudis wird gleich
behandelt wie ein treibstoff der aus co2
mit windenergie umgewandelt worden ist
in beispielsweise ein benzin obwohl das
klimaneutral ist und das ist ein
schweres politisches versagen zu wirkt
eine schlüsselindustrie ab und trägt
nicht dazu bei dass wir schnell
klimaziele erreichen bevor wir die
themen gleich weiter vertiefen
ich wollte mal ganz kurz bei der partei
die linke bleiben ist es vielleicht auch
für die linke regionalpolitisch so
gewesen man hat die zahlen ja auch vor
den letzten landtagswahlen gesehen
welche themen sind jeweils wo vor ort am
wichtigsten und am meisten aus deutschen
bundesländern weil er eben nicht so wie
in den meisten westdeutschen
bundesländern klimaschutz ganz oben
aktuell ist das auch so dass die linke
sagt das ist vielleicht nicht ganz
unseren thema nein es geht gar nicht
darum wenn man mit leuten spricht dann
ist es in der regel so fast jeder macht
sich sorgen wenn die umwelt zerstört
wird das ist ja nicht nur eine frage des
co2 ausstoß ist da geht es um
artensterben
geht es um mikro plastik da geht es
einfach um die vergiftung von seen und
von mehreren also all diese fragen dass
wir unsere natürliche lebensgrundlage
zerstören das bewegt jeden menschen
aber wenn dann eben zum beispiel in
einer region wie der lausitz die leute
die dort einer einzigen arbeitgeber
haben bei dem sie noch gute jobs haben
und das ist die kohle und dann kommt die
politik und sagt na ja gut da müssen wir
raus kümmert sich aber und das weiß man
seit jahren dass das irgendwann
natürlich eine technologie ist die man
nicht mehr nutzen kann kümmert sich aber
seit jahren nicht darum dass irgendetwas
anderes dort entsteht lässt sogar auch
dinge kaputt gehen wir hatten zum
beispiel meine soll ein solarindustrie
in deutschland die hat man komplett
kaputt gehen lassen so und dann sagen
natürlich die leute die dort ihren job
haben ja was was wird aus meiner region
wenn die kohle hier weggeht dann werde
ich eine von diesen abhängigen regionen
wo meine kinder meine enkel nur noch
wegziehen können
und natürlich will das niemand und das
ist auch genau das richtige sein dass
soziale bei den klimaschutz zu verbinden
deshalb wird die linke damit noch nicht
so in der öffentlichkeit wahrgenommen
also ich glaube schon dass wir zum
beispiel sind eine der ganz wenigen
politischen kräfte die von anfang an
dagegen gekämpft haben die bahn zur
börsen bahn zu machen also die
privatisierung der bahn hat ja
wesentlich dazu beigetragen dass so
viele strecken stillgelegt wurden weil
es muss sich jetzt alles rechnen alles
so profitabel werden die infrastruktur
wurde auf verschleiß gefahren das war
immer unser thema das war nicht so sehr
das grüne thema oder von anderen
parteien also insoweit war das immer
unser thema aber gerade diese verbindung
ist wichtig weil ich mache mir sorgen
dass zur zeit der klimaschutz wirklich
ein thema wird dass dieses land massiv
spaltet weil es auf der einen seite eben
im städtischen milieu natürlich andere
interessen gibt da ist zum beispiel auch
windkraft wird mich in prenzlauer berg
vor der eigentumswohnung errichtet aber
im ländlichen bereich vor dem eigenheim
und das ist nicht durch einen
wertverlust des hauses und ich glaube
wir sollten aufhören diese debatte so
moralisch aufzuladen also bist du für
oder gegen das klima also ich glaube
jeder mensch wünscht sich dass diese
erde und das klima erhalten bleibt aber
es muss so laufen dass nicht wieder die
die zeche zahlen die immer für alle
krisen zur kasse gebeten
den punkt auf nehme die gesellschaft
nicht zu spalten ist dann dieses klima
paket der bundesregierung nicht genau
das richtige weil ich ja keine so
richtig weh tut es ist zunächst mal
unwirksam und es ist teuer und die 54
milliarden euro die werden von
irgendjemanden aufgebracht werden
wir haben jetzt in den vergangenen
jahren schon eine energiepolitik erlebt
nach einem ähnlichen strickmuster jedes
jahr etwa 28 29 milliarden euro
subventionen die werden aufgebracht vom
bafög empfänger und von der rentnerin
und sichern die garantierte rendite von
windkraft investoren paradoxerweise
selbst dann wenn keine stromleitung und
kein stromspeicher da ist das heißt die
energie noch nicht mal genutzt werden
kann und das kann doch nicht weiter
fortgesetzt werden ich bin deshalb der
meinung dass wir zunächst einmal darüber
sprechen sollten was ist der günstigste
weg nicht der rigoroses sondern der
günstigste weg unsere klimaziele zu
erreichen
und da muss ich zweifel an welchem sinne
von klimaziele 2030 40-50 mit weniger
euro pro tonne und erreichen wir haben
in der finanziell des günstigsten
natürlich warum auch nicht
wir haben momentan die höchsten co2
vermeidungskosten auf der welt das heißt
so viel wie eine tonne co2 einzusparen
in deutschland ist so teuer wie
nirgendwo sonst auf der welt dann muss
man doch mal nachdenken ob da irgendwas
falsch ist weil niemand wird wird
unseren weg da folgen
und ich glaube dass wir auf unsere gute
alte marktwirtschaft setzen sollten denn
denn co2 ist ein knappes gut
es darf nicht mehr viel davon verbraucht
bzw ausgestoßen werden der beste
mechanismus um mit knappen ressourcen
umzugehen war nicht der sozialismus der
sowjetunion die erinnern uns war auch
nicht das modell hugo chavez in
venezuela sondern der beste mechanismus
mit knappen ressourcen umzugehen ist die
kreativität der menschen
der ideenwettbewerb der wunsch kosten zu
sparen und gewinne zu erhöhen und genau
diesen mechanismus der marktwirtschaft
den sollten wir jetzt für ökologische
ziele nutzen wir sollen ihn als spannend
für ökologie glauben sie in dem fall
auch an den markt und das über den weg
geregelt wird
glauben sie der stadt an dieser habe
einfach mal wir glauben ja jetzt alle
oder zumindest die politik schon seit
vielen jahren an den markt deswegen hat
sie ja zum beispiel diesen co2
emissionshandel auf europäischer ebene
installiert er hat de facto nicht viel
gebracht das muss man einfach
konstatieren das war ein geschäftsmodell
für unternehmen und logen aber das ist
natürlich dass es wirklich sinnvoll ist
den unternehmen vorgaben zu machen weil
ich weil sie es einfach von alleine
nicht einlösen und das ist eben ein
großes problem wenn ich mir angucke wir
haben unternehmen es gibt ja gerade eine
studie des sparkassenverbandes die haben
heute doppelt so hohe gewinne wie sie
vor der letzten krise hatten also sie
haben sozusagen ihre profitabilität
extrem erhöht ganz besonders die großen
konzerne so was haben sie mit dem geld
machen der deutschen bank zu vertreten
ich rede von den 30 dax konzernen das
ist zum glück nicht nur die deutsche
bank die deutsche wirtschaft ausmacht
und selbst ja schon ganz anders aus so
also von den 30 dax konzernen
so was haben die mit ihren gewinnen
gemacht die hälfte der gewinne wird
heutzutage ausgeschüttet in form von
dividenden das war nicht immer so früher
wurden die man investiert heute werden
sie ausgeschüttet dann machen sie
aktienrückkäufe
sie haben ein extrem kurzfristiges
geschäftsmodell das heißt investitionen
in langfristige forschung die sich auch
erst langfristig rentiert ist in diesen
aktiengesellschaften nicht vorgesehen
und das gegenmodell sind viele mittlere
unternehmen das sind die hidden
champions die wirklich technologieführer
sind aber gerade bei den großen
unternehmen die auch von der politik
immer wieder gepäppelt werden sehe ich
dass wir in den letzten jahren unsere
ganze technologieführerschaft verspielt
haben wir sind in keiner einzigen
zukunftstechnologie wäre bei
digitalisierung noch bei den grünen
technologien irgendwie weltmarktführer
und es hat was mit diesem
geschäftsmodell zu tun und deswegen muss
ich sagen die unternehmen hatten ihre
chance gerade die großen hier geht es
jetzt wirklich darum auch vorgaben zu
machen die sie einhalten weil sonst
passieren einfach nicht mit müssen wir
aufpassen dass wir einander vorbei reden
weil ich möchte auch vorgaben haben
nämlich die vorgabe zum beispiel
klimafreundlich zu produzieren
wer co2 ausstößt der soll das bezahlen
soll sich eigentlich an die konsumenten
weiter das ist ja alles klar
ich mache ihnen auch gleich noch ein
vorschlag wie das gelöst werden kann
also wer co2 ausstößt soll zahlen egal
ob ein unternehmen aber auch sie und ich
wenn wir was bei
autofahren fleisch essen eine reise
machen wir sollten für unseren co2
fußabdruck bezahlen und das ist ja die
die interessante frage die dann daran
knüpft ist alle werden versuchen
natürlich möglichst wenig zu bezahlen
für das co2 werden also co2 vermeiden
und dann wissen wir noch gar nicht auf
welchem weg das geht ich bleibe bei
ihrem bahn beispiel eine bahnstrecke die
nicht rentabel ist und geschlossen wird
die war auch fürs klima nicht gut weil
die waggons hätten nur heiße luft
transportiert und keine passagiere da
ist möglicherweise ist möglicherweise
ein hybridfahrzeug wo drei leute drin
sitzen viel ökologischer als eine
bahnstrecke aufrecht zu erhalten und das
kann man eben nicht pauschal beantworten
deshalb ist so an co2 mechanismus du
zahlst übernimmst verantwortung und
suchst eine vermeidungsstrategie der
beste weg um ihre soziale frage will ich
gerne auch beantworten frau wagenknecht
denn sie haben eben völlig zu recht
gesagt ist droht eine spaltung der
gesellschaft viele wähler der grünen gut
verdient in hamburg die können sich auch
riesige co2 preise leisten und müssen
nichts an ihrem leben verändern
im handwerksbetrieb einer werkbank wird
man es aber merken da wird man weniger
verdienen und möglicherweise wird
mancher betrieb in die knie gehen also
ist eine ganz wichtige frage
mein vorschlag ist die einnahmen die der
staat erzielt aus dem verkauf der co2
rechte die sollte er pro kopf an die
menschen ausschütten
das ist ja der standard konzept und
meines erachtens ist es augenwischerei
so zu tun als würde das die sozialen
ungerechtigkeiten ausgleichen weil das
wäre zwar tatsächlich für die ganz armen
also für menschen denen es richtig
schlecht geht wenn es nicht am ende an
auf hartz 4 sätze angerechnet wird was
ich in diesem land er für wahrscheinlich
halte aber dann würde es bei den ärmsten
tatsächlich ein plus geben aber zb die
mittelschicht die auf dem lande lebt die
im haus hat was jetzt nicht das super
co2 komfort haus also nicht das super
wärmedämm haus ist sondern einfach ein
normales einfamilienhaus das vielleicht
eine ölheizung hat weil es da gibt es
kein gas und da gibt's sonst nix so und
das eben auch keine öffentliche
anbindung hat das also aufs auto
angewiesen ist und sich jetzt auch nicht
den tollen elektro schlitten leisten
kann
diese familie zahlt drauf und zwar ein
sehr beträchtlichen
braucht ja viel co2 aber nicht weil sie
das aus jux und dollerei macht weil sie
zehn fernflüge im jahr macht sondern
weil das einfach ihr lebensumfeld
bedingt und wenn die politik nicht dafür
sorgt dass es alternativen gebe zum
beispiel fernwärme ausbaut und vieles
andere mehr sind die eine hand stoffel
haben sie alles haben sie keine chance
und ich will auch nochmals zudem
rentabilität argument sagen bei der bahn
also dass eine strecke sich rechnet
heißt ja oder sich nicht rechnet im
sinne von rentabel zu sein heißt ja
nicht dass da keiner fährt das heißt nun
das nicht so viele fahren dass man
richtig dicke profite damit machen kann
ist es auch erst mal vorher ja ich finde
schon dass es sinnvoll ist und selbst
wenn das dann eben pro tag mehrere
hundert leute sind und wir sehen zb
aktuell krasses beispiel bei der
gütersparte als die bahn ist ja durchaus
in der lage güterverkehr in ziemlichem
umfang abzuwickeln das hat sie früher
mal gemacht und wir haben in den letzten
jahren immer mehr verlagerung von der
schiene auf die straße also die endlosen
kolonnen der lkws das ist eine riesige
co2 sünder
es ist auch nicht gerade zum vorteil der
autofahrer die sonst auf der straße sind
weil es natürlich zum stau beitrag trägt
und die bahn hat jetzt wieder
angekündigt ihre ihrer not leidende
sparte weil sie das einfach nicht
richtig gemanagt kriegt das
güterverkehrsaufkommen jetzt noch weiter
abstürzen rechnete vielleicht auch noch
mal ganz sollte der alles wird sollten
wir alle weniger bei amazon und zalando
bestellen denn das ist der grund warum
er auf den straßen passiere auch darüber
wenn wir entsprechend wie wir alle
vielleicht unser verhalten ändern müssen
oder können wollen uns aber ganz kurz
einen ausschnitt anschauen die
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel zum
klimapaket in der pressekonferenz hat
sich freitag dort ja erklärt und eben
auch was in der politik weil so ein
paket geschnürt wurde überhaupt möglich
ist wenn mich etwas beeindruckt das sage
ich jetzt mal als naturwissenschaftlerin
dann ist das wenn greta turmberg sagt
uniteis behind this 1 es ist nicht so
dass wir hier irgendetwas in
theologisches machen sollen wir machen
etwas wofür so massive evidenzen gibt
dass wir dagegen handeln muss
nun werden sie fragen was haben wir da
die vielen stunden getan und die vielen
stunden schon vorher
und da darf ich ihnen sagen dass das ein
beispiel für das ist was politik ist das
unterscheidet politik auch von
wissenschaft und auch von ungeduldigen
jungen menschen politik ist das ist die
dass das was möglich ist und die
möglichkeiten die haben wir ausgelotet
mit unterschiedlichen herkünften mit
unterschiedlichen schwerpunkten in
unserer arbeit und für mich ist sehr
wichtig dass ich durch dieses papier was
wir ihnen heute vorliegen
erstens sieht dass wir daran glauben
dass wir die ziele erreichen können und
dass wir dafür auch wirklich die
grundlagen gelegt haben dass man die
bundeskanzlerin am freitag sehr betont
die politik kann nur dass mögliche
machen
herr lindner bei der co2 bepreisung
diese zehn euro pro tonne
die in ungefähr drei cent pro liter
sprit umgerechnet werden das doch gar
keinen effekt oder nein
deshalb ist es hier ab bemerkenswert
dass frau merkel sich tatsächlich auf
die wissenschaft beruft alle
wissenschaftler klimaforscher wie
wirtschaftswissenschaftler haben dieses
paket in der luft zerrissen weil es so
sagen die die ein nicht regieren genug
ist nicht genug verbote und nicht zu
hohe teuerung enthält und andere
wissenschaftler sagen die möglichkeit
die die es gebe mit einem co2
handelsmodell günstig co2 zielgerichtet
einzusparen
die werden nicht genutzt war so ein
merkwürdiger kompromiss ist und deshalb
wenn man sich an der wissenschaft
orientiert
das jedenfalls käme dann nicht raus als
ergebnis ist es auch ihre meinung dass
also die frage ist ja die die
lenkungswirkung das was wir eben
bevor wir den den ausschnitt gesehen
haben angesprochen haben also wann
verändern wir alle auch unser verhalten
dann leben wir an das brauchen wir da
höhere preise erst noch mal die
lenkungswirkung hängt davon ab dass es
überhaupt andere optionen gibt wenn es
die optionen nicht gibt kann ich den co2
preis auf 100 euro auf 300 euro setzen
und irgendwann bleibt der gehen
vielleicht zu hause weil sich der job
nicht mehr lohnt aber das ist ja
vielleicht nicht das was wir wollen das
jetzt heißt das ist ein mehr als die 10
euro hätten sie auch nicht für richtig
gefunden aktuell
ich halte das ganze instrument und ich
halte das schon falsches instrument und
ich habe auch die große befürchtung dass
es natürlich nicht bei den zehn euro es
soll ja auch steigen auf 35 ich habe
auch die befürchtung wird bei 35 nicht
bleiben das ist ein einstieg in eine
verbrauchssteuer de facto wirkt es ja so
und die wird weiter erhöht werden weil
man ganz erschrocken irgendwann
feststellen das hat ja gar nichts
bewirkt natürlich bewirkt das so nicht
aber vielmehr würde es bewirken zum
beispiel den unternehmen auflagen zu
machen was die haltbarkeit ihrer
produkte angeht wir haben eine
unglaubliche wegwerf wirtschaft das
heißt viele sachen werden so produziert
dass sie nicht lange halten das ist
sogar kalkül dass man sie wegschmeißt
das nächste kauf weil sie nicht
reparabel sind
das ist ein solche verschwendung von
ressourcen auch von co2 da ist ein ein
riesiges potenzial so dann haben wir da
sind wir sogar einig alternative
antriebe da wird man jetzt eben rennt
man diese elektromobilität hinterher
obwohl man wissen kann dass das keine
zukunftstechnologie ist weil die
rohstoffe einfach gar nicht in der
ausreichenden menge da sind und außerdem
selber unter sehr sehr negativen
bedingungen gewonnen werden also
lithium- zerstört riesige landstriche da
wächst dann nichts mehr und kobold wird
unter ganz katastrophalen bedingungen im
kongo zum beispiel gefördert also hier
dass das ist keine technologie mit der
man wirklich in der zukunft bestehen
kann außerdem ist auch ein recycling
problem keiner weiß was die ganzen
batterien wenn sie auslaufen und die
halten ja nur begrenzt was man damit
macht aber da wird erst mal blind gesagt
das ist ja jetzt sozusagen schon eine
entwickelte technologie die
automobilkonzerne freuen sich weil sie
so ihre durchschnittswerte nach unten
rechnen können also geht man jetzt auf
diese technologie steuerlich zuvor nach
außen magnet also wir sind manchem punkt
der überraschenderweise einig aber in
einem punkt nicht also die
pauschalkritik an unternehmen und
wirtschaft die will ich mal relativ
gelassen und wer relativieren denn
machen lassen sich nicht aus folgenden
hohen will ich es tun
sie sprechen über die unternehmen die
großen konzerne die wirtschaft wir alle
sind die wirtschaft auch als differenz
auch millionen und großen es gibt auch
millionen beschäftigte bei den dax
unternehmen die haben dann sicheren gut
bezahlten arbeitsplatz und deshalb will
ich mal vor der pauschalverurteilung
egal welches unternehmens welcher größe
warnen
entscheidend ist doch folgendes wir
haben eine automobilwirtschaft die durch
den irrweg den sie auch gerade
beschrieben haben sich einseitig auf
batterie elektrische antriebe zu
konzentrieren
die wird geschwächt die freuen sich doch
nicht du brauchst doch viel weniger
beschäftigte für ein e auto dessen
standardkomponenten verbrennungsmotor
mit getriebe das sind viele beschäftigte
wasserstoff sind immerhin noch ein paar
mehr beschäftigte und wir führen jetzt
politisch gewollt unsere
schlüsselbranche automobilwirtschaft
weltweit immer noch führend die führen
wir jetzt in eine sackgasse hinein wo
andere beispielsweise in japan selbst
längst wasserstoff machen und daher fust
würde ich ansetzen
wir brauchen klare politische
rahmenbedingungen aber aber ich bin
politikwissenschaftler
ich kann doch nicht im parlament über
technologien entscheiden und frau göring
eckardt von den grünen ist theologien
also die die hat gelernt fest an etwas
zu glauben willst nicht nicht zu
wirklich machen aber die hat jedenfalls
auch kein technisches wissen und deshalb
muss die politik einen rahmen setzen und
danach sollen die verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher durch ihre entscheidungen
unternehmen durch den wunsch gewinne zu
erzielen oder kosten zu senken die
sollten den weg in die zukunft ebnen
das ist viel günstiger als das was jetzt
auf den wetten dass doch längst machen
können also das ist ja das problem ich
teile das ja also ich fühle mich jetzt
auch nicht berufen im bundestag darüber
zu entscheiden welche technologie die
zukunftstechnologie ist ich habe nur
große zweifel bei der die jetzt zur
auswahl stehen nur das problem ist doch
warum haben denn ich meine wir haben
große autounternehmen die haben in den
letzten fünf jahren über 100 milliarden
euro gewinne gemacht warum haben sie
nicht massiv geforscht und so doch ein
haben sie gar nicht übrig schneller
werden wir doch führend in dem bereich
denn sie auf sie hören wir sind führend
beim verbrennungsmotor da waren wir
führend und dass es tatsächlich die
spezialität der deutschen autoindustrie
wenn wir jetzt tatsächlich bei
synthetischen kraftstoffen oder zb bei
der brennstoffzelle welt führen wären
dann wäre das ja eine alternative ich
teile
sich dass die batterie am ende für die
deutsche autoindustrie eine katastrophe
ist weil tatsächlich geschafft die
ganzen fähigkeiten die wir haben nicht
gebraucht werden und das ist im grunde
auch ein versagen dieses management
gegenüber den eigenen beschäftigten weil
sie stellen natürlich deren jobs in
frage aber immer das kann doch nicht
also wenn die unternehmen das nicht
bringen und wie gesagt herr dies von vw
hat ganz klar gesagt also wir brauchen
hier keine technologieoffenheit wir
machen jetzt elektro und aber das ist
man sich aus weil das soll die nächsten
fälle zu hause zu bringen aber
ausgerechnet vw ist ein schlechtes
beispiel weil das unternehmen gehört dem
staat eindrücken von der ig metall stark
besteuert also na ja jetzt pauschal
kritik an der wirtschaft ich muss
nochmal zurück wahl hätte ja auch ein
drittel aller forschungs privaten
forschungsausgaben kommt aus der
automobilwirtschaft wir sind weltweit
führend mit den patenten auch im bereich
e mobilität und wasserstoff aber die
politik wollte doch dass es überwiegend
um den diesel geht da gab es doch gab es
doch ein steuerrabatt wenn man weiß die
autokonzerne wollen gar nicht fragen
keine fahrverbote in ingolstadt träume
ganz kurz es ist ja heute ungefähr die
bundesregierung über die wir sprechen
das paket die sitzt nicht mit am tisch
deswegen muss ich die eine frage
unbedingt stellen was ist denn aus ihrer
sicht das stärkste element dieses immer
paket wenn wir schon kritik die ganze
zeit äußern an dem paket muss man einmal
drauf gucken ganz fair was ist was ist
das stärkste volle elemente also zum
beispiel gebäude gebäudedämmung
voranzutreiben ist absolut sinnvoll es
ist auch sinnvoll sicherlich den strom
zu verbilligen wobei sie das was sie da
wirklich beschlossen haben das ist auch
wieder ein schlechter witz also der
strompreis ist so hoch wie die und jetzt
sagen sie irgendwie mit ich weiß nicht
12 cent würde da sich groß was ändern
also da man die richtung ist richtig
aber dieses ausmaß ist eben völlig
unzureichend und deswegen wird es eben
tatsächlich auch nicht viel bewirken das
ganze paket
sie kennen sie einen positiven punkt an
dem paket 2 regelmäßiges monitoring das
ist gut aber dazu führen dass
auf mittlere sicht dieses ganze paket
zusammenfällt wenn man sieht es ist
nicht der richtige weg
in der tat die frage der
gebäudesanierung denn wir reden über
verbot von innerdeutschen flügen und
machen das auto zum feind bilden regler
kultur kampf ist da entbrannt der
wesentliche punkt ist gebäude gebäude
das ist der der größte bereich ist der
schlafende riese des klimaschutzes
wenn wir mal dafür sorgen dass unsere
gebäude effizienter sind und das wird
steuerlich nicht gefördert bisher
wir haben milliarden und abermilliarden
für erneuerbare energien ausgegeben an
subventionen
aber was man nicht getan haben ist das
naheliegendste zu tun damit dafür zu
sorgen dass die gebäude im vernünftigen
zustand sind und da konnte der bund mal
vorangehen
bei seinen bundesimmobilien auch da muss
man natürlich darauf achten und das ist
dann wieder das defizit das nicht am
ende
die mieten die sowieso schon seit vielen
jahren extrem steigen noch weiter
angetrieben werden also ich finde schon
dass man da in der regel einführen muss
dass am ende die warmmiete also die
heizkosten sinken ja aber dass zumindest
die warmmiete nicht höher ist als vorher
das heißt dass mit der
modernisierungsumlage das hätte man
natürlich anders regeln müssen und da
sind wir bei dem punkt wäre das ganze
zeit 54 milliarden euro mindestens die
hier aufgebracht werden für die
pendlerpauschale für alles was
unterstützt wird wer soll es denn
bezahlen ja darüber schweigt sich die
regierung teilweise aus aber wir wissen
ja wer in deutschland immer alles zahlt
wäre ja auch den größten teil der
steuern zahlt das ist die mittelschicht
das sind nicht die wirklich reichen das
sind auch nicht die großen unternehmen
sind eher die mittleren und kleinen die
großen können sich vor vielen steuern
drücken weil sie einfach ihre
internationalen strukturen haben daran
ändert sich leider auch nicht wer sollte
es sind zahlen bei selbst wenn sie mit
an der regierung wären könnten wir diese
riesen zahlen und es werden dann auch
noch viel mehr dass wir es jetzt nur bis
2023 das komplett der wirtschaft in
unternehmen aufzulegen wäre auch nicht
gut und wir haben ja seit jahren einen
trend der gerade die reichsten von
steuern entlastet wir sind eines der
ganz wenigen länder der ganz wenigen
industrieländer die keine
vermögensbesteuerung haben andere länder
haben das wir haben eine extrem niedrige
erbschaftssteuer obwohl wir immer
größere erbschaften haben immer größere
vermögen in wenigen händen also da reden
wir nicht über das was die kleinen leute
sich erarbeitet haben sondern wirklich
über millionen und milliarden vermögen
das ist alles draußen und natürlich bei
den unter
nehmen muss man eben unterscheiden wir
haben einerseits den körperschaftsteuer
aber wir haben große unternehmen die die
großen teil ihrer gewinne ebenso
international jonglieren können dass
etwa 40 prozent nicht besteuert werden
das sind ja die zahlen die
internationale studien herausbringen und
da ist natürlich auch das problem die
bundesregierung gehört zu den großen
bremsen also ganz persönlich auch olaf
scholz als finanzminister unterscheidet
sich darin nichts von herrn schäuble
vorher zum großen bremsen auch auf
europäischer ebene eine bessere
unternehmens und konzern besteuerung
hinzubekommen hat sogar blockiert dass
das wenigstens öffentlich gemacht wird
was sie in den einzelnen ländern
verdienen und was sie woanders besteuern
ich meine frankreich holt sich gerade
von den digital konzernen eine milliarde
zurück wegen nicht gezahlter steuern im
digitalbereich andere länder ähnlich in
deutschland wir gucken einfach nur zu
und das ist ein riesen problem dann
liegt hier viel geld brach was wir
nutzen könnten
ist die deutsche bundesregierung der
zuletzt gegenüber den großen unternehmen
heißen nicht ganz so einfach das zu
lösen ich bin jedenfalls ganz stolz dass
meine partei freundin frau festtage
gegen das steuerdumping von apple in
irland vorgegangen absolvent genau also
das ist wahr eine liberale initiative es
muss fairness geben die größe des
unternehmens darf nicht entscheiden
darüber wie viel steuern gezahlt werden
ist allerdings nicht ganz einfach frau
wagenknecht sprach selbst eben einen
hidden champions aus dem mittelstand die
sind überall in der welt aktiv und
verkaufen ihre produkte vor steuern aber
bei uns wenn das modell was wenn das
modell was sie fordern politik wird dann
wird der hidden champion der aus dem
hochschwarzwald kommt ein teil seiner
gewinne eben auch der volksrepublik
china versteuern das ist alles nicht so
ein sagte er der meinung ist folgender
wir haben doch mal zunächst die frage zu
stellen wie können wir die kosten
insgesamt reduzieren ich bin noch gar
nicht über die 54 milliarden sprechen
wir reden bis 2050 über 2,5 billionen
euro das ist die größenordnung die der
bdi beispielsweise vor wenigen jahren
mal errechnet hat wir reden über 2,5
billionen euro und wir müssen doch
erstmal alles tun ein system eine
politik auf zu setzen
die diese kosten reduziert wir haben die
höchsten strompreise in europa vor
fehlen aber die klimaziele weil wir das
planwirtschaftliche mit subventionen an
gehen das können wir doch jetzt nicht
bei der viel größeren aufgabe des
klimawandels und der in seiner
bekämpfung wiederholen und danach herr
fuß am ende zahlt die breite mitte der
gesellschaft das was die politik
entscheidet in der tat ganz großen
einkommen sind ja gar nicht mehr in
deutschland zuhause der fußballprofis
haben ihren wohnsitz oder anders die
leute die nicht anders können die sind
dann in deutschland dass die gehobene
mittelschicht die hat übrigens auch eine
entlastung verdient und deren interessen
muss man auch sehen und dass die
schwarze null die ja so heilig ist seit
einigen jahren dies nach vielen
jahrzehnten jetzt wieder gab es seit
einigen jahren die vielleicht auch auf
weichen um investieren zu können
das hört man aus der cdu auch die grünen
sind ja für neuschulden ich kann davor
nur warnen
wir haben nämlich heute schon enorme
lasten auf der generation der kinder und
enkel die beamten pensionen und auch die
bestehenden anwartschaften in der
gesetzlichen rentenversicherung
milliarden und abermilliarden die müssen
alle in den nächsten jahren gezahlt
werden die sind in der offiziellen
staatsverschuldung gar nicht drin
wir sind jetzt bei unter 60 prozent
bezogen auf die jährliche
wirtschaftsleistung aber dass alles was
die junge generation noch zahlen muss
ist dann nicht ausgewiesen sind wie wir
sind das schlechter als italien und will
das argument italien noch in einem
fortsetzen wenn wir in deutschland
anfang der politik auf pump zu machen
statt mal beim br bei diesen flughafen
zu sparen solche verschwendung
subventionen zu streichen also wenn wir
sagen wir gehen den einfachsten weg wir
machen schulden statt den staat
schlanker und konzentrierter
dann ist das doch eine einladung für
eine regierung in italien zu sagen dann
machen wir auch wieder neue schulden und
dann sind wir wieder mittendrin in der
euro-schuldenkrise der letzten jahre
das heißt deutschland weiter vorbild
sein die frage ist wo ring der welt sind
also in italien ist in einer schweren
wirtschaftskrise da wäre es absolut
sinnvoll wenn sie investitionsprogramme
staatlich machen würden und wenn sie das
auch teilweise über kredit finanzieren
würden und ich meine in deutschland ist
in der speziellen situation dass der der
bund aktuell geld geschenkt bekommt also
wenn man negative zinsen hat dann hat
man ja de facto weniger zurück zu
ein als man bekommt also so eine
situation würde sich mancher unternehmer
erträumen also manche großen haben sogar
aber kleine und normale verbraucher
haben das natürlich nie die zahlen immer
mehr an ihrer bank zurück als sie
bekommen bei dem bund ist es umgekehrt
und wenn immer das argument der
zukünftigen generationen angeführt wird
natürlich ist es auch nicht besonders
schön der zukünftigen generation ein
land zu hinterlassen wo die rücken
marode sind wohl nur jede dritte kommune
ein schnelles internet hat wo einfach in
der infrastruktur immer mehr verfällt wo
wir auch unsere schlechte bildung
leisten meint niemand sagt doch jetzt im
ernst wir sollen schulden aufnehmen um
beamtenpension aufzustocken also ich
meine ich auch noch keinen gehört ist
doch unsinn erzählt da war was los
nein es geht um investitionen in die
zukunft und glauben jedes unternehmen
sie das ja was heißt glaube ich kann ja
nur sagen was ich vertrete und wofür ich
kämpfen würde also das kann man
natürlich sagen okay also weil die
politiker die da immer regieren ich
meinen ihre partei war ja auch genügend
zeit dabei weil die immer mist gemacht
haben sagen wir jetzt also der staat
soll möglichst gar kein geld mehr
doch sinnvoller gibt es die schulden
jahren so die schwarze dabei sinnvoll
ist es nicht sinnvoll ist eben nicht
jeder unternehmer finanziert seine
investitionen auch über kredit das ist
ein normales modell das zahlt sich aus
man darf nur nicht über kredit jetzt
konsumtive ausgaben oder den berliner
flughafen verkehren
aber das ist doch nicht der sinn der
realität ist doch wir hatten 2008 9 eine
wirtschaftskrise
damals gab es ein konjunkturpaket der
großen koalition mit verstand ja auch
die krise hat sich abgesetzt 10
milliarden euro schwer war dieses paket
und es hieß das wird ganz rasch
abgezahlt zehn jahre später tilgung 0
nichts doch gar nicht so haben ja sogar
in den letzten jahren die waren ja wie
verrückt dabei ständig überschüsse zum
sergej können die zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer können das jetzt ja googeln
die schulden die fürs konjunkturpaket 2
aufgenommen worden so dicke haben aber
den idealen überschüsse erwirtschaftet
und wir haben gleich nach jürgen und
bürger haben überschuss er geschafft
aber nicht sie ja aber dass deutschland
hat überschüsse im staatshaushalt
schulen geschäftet zur stunde nicht
wir wollen sinnvolle ausgaben lassen
beispiel eine bessere bildung die wir
dringend braucht bin ich ganz bei ihnen
es geht die ländergrenzen von investiert
worden
wir haben in teilbereichen baubereich
einfach voller auslastung es gibt keine
keine tiefbau ingenieure mehr wenn man
da sagte investieren jetzt noch mehr
jetzt ist nicht der zeitpunkt dafür sei
die wirtschaft die wirtschaft der ist
gerade nicht mehr so gut geht wie noch
in den vergangenen jahren das gerade in
dieser situation so ein großes projekt
der klimaschutz auf uns zukommt der
soviel kostet und bei der schuldenbremse
eine klausel gibt es ja tatsächlich wenn
es der wirtschaft richtig schlecht geht
dass vorübergehend tatsächlich die
schwarze null in einer klausel dort
verankert dass die schwarze nur
gebrochen werden kann
aber das geld natürlich zurückgezahlt
werden muss wann kommt so ein moment wie
schlecht muss es der wirtschaft gehen
was auch sie sagen na ja ja das müssen
wir einfach mal die schwarze null
brechen ich hoffe dieser moment kommt
nicht und bevor ich anfange wieder neue
schulden zu machen es hat eine hohe
symbolische wirkung sage ich nur würde
ich doch erst mal anfangen zu überlegen
wie kann der staat besser mit geld
umgehen
diese wird diese patent deutschland
überhaupt gar nicht mehr geführt sie
sagen mehr für die bildung sie sitzen
doch in brandenburg und berlin in der
regierung der flughafen der flughafen
berlin brandenburg kostet glaube ich
jede woche zehn millionen euro
dass er nicht eröffnet wird die zehn
millionen könnte man in brandenburg in
die bildung investieren also bevor wir
darüber nachdenken die steuern zu
erhöhen schulden zu machen
gehen wir doch mit dem vielen vielen
vielen geld das da ist einfach mal
besser und ich mussten bei ihrer frage
einsatz nachsagen sie sagen jetzt in
dieser schwierigen wirtschaftslage kommt
auch noch der klimaschutz oben drauf
wenn wir den klimaschutz richtig machen
dann kann das ein wachstumstreiber sein
wenn wir nämlich spannende tolle
klimafreundliche technologien haben die
werden uns auf den weltmärkten aus den
händen gerissen werbeinvestitionen
braucht es doch natürlich und deshalb
bin ich ja ein vertreter einer partei
die sagt wir können es uns nicht leisten
dass er mittlerweile die nahezu höchsten
steuer und abgabenbelastung weltweit
haben und zwar so dass
das stimmt auch nicht wieso ist ein
vermögen
liebe frau wagenknecht auf einen
ausgeschütteten gewinn beträgt der
steuersatz 48,34 das wissen sie auch die
dividende wird mit 48 34 prozent
versteuert kann jeder der zuschauerinnen
und zuschauer mal googeln wo außer
vielleicht venezuela solle belastung auf
der welt noch gibt und ob das die
referenzbeispiele sind an denen wir uns
orientieren sollten also ich verstehe ja
völlig dass die fdp auch immer auf dem
berliner flughafen bereitet weil sich da
eben wirklich völlig ist staatsversagen
gezeigt hat das ist ja eindeutig so
trotzdem finde ich dass ein bisschen
billig weil es heißt natürlich nicht
dass der staat jetzt überall solche
flughäfen bauen soll
und ich stimme ihnen ja sogar in einem
punkt zu also ein sinnvolleres ein
sinnvoller umgang mit dem steuergeld der
bürger der wäre tatsächlich sehr sehr
angebracht wenn ich mir alleine angucken
wie der rüstungs haushalt in den letzten
jahren explodiert ist damit könnte man
wirklich sinnvolleres machen also da
will ich nicht widersprechen
aber ich finde man sollte das nicht
immer so gegeneinander stellen also wenn
wir jetzt über große notwendige
investitionen reden in bildung
infrastruktur in besseren nah und
fernverkehr in digitalisierung da muss
man nicht so tun als wäre das dadurch
finanzierbar dass man aufhört den br zu
bauen
also das ist einfach in der relation
liegt für trainer das ist ein was sie
lieben weil es zeigt dass der staat
unfähig ist und bestimmte jähriger und
filme aber es zeigt doch nicht so wohl
anderer länder an die vielfach
infrastruktur investiert haben die sind
deutlich besser da die funkverbindung
deutlich besser als die stimmung total
zu warum aber weil der staat nämlich bei
den mobilfunk lizenzen maximales geld
haben wollen das haben wir jetzt ja
schon wieder andere länder haben gesagt
wir geben euch die frequenzen nicht so
wichtig wie viel geld ihr zahlt ihr
müsst nur schnell ein flächendeckendes
netz haben in deutschland keine haben es
noch einfach in deutschland hat in
deutschland hat hans eichel damals vor
urzeiten gesagt ich will maximales geld
haben egal wenn es ein paar funklöcher
gibt und das sollte man nicht noch ein
weiteres mal wiederholen ich hatte ja
vorher gesagt sehr viele gemeinsamkeiten
wird es nicht geben
ich wollte aber noch mal ein
frage zur wirtschaft insgesamt stellen
wo steht die wirtschaft wo hingeht sie
alle sprechen von der rezession
die wirtschaft steht am beginn einer
strukturellen wirtschaftskrise wir haben
es nicht zu tun mit ein bisschen
konjunktur wo wir da irgendwie
rumfummeln können sondern wir haben eine
strukturelle krise hängt zusammen mit
handelskonflikten in der welt dem
drohenden bretone die großen
veränderungen umstrukturierungen in der
wirtschaft selbst durch die
digitalisierung auch hausgemachte
probleme kommen dazu starke überlastung
mit bürokratie und in finanzieller weise
bei mittelstand und handwerk das
zusammengenommen fachkräftemangel weil
wir unser bildungssystem nicht
finanziert haben in vernünftiger weise
das führt zusammengenommen zu einer
strukturkrise und auf eine strukturkrise
kann man auch nur mit tiefgreifenden
strukturellen reformen antworten sehen
sie es genauso also zum teil hausgemacht
zum teil von außen ich sehe tatsächlich
auch sehr große und unser beängstigende
krisen potenziale das ist zum einen
vieles von dem was sie gesagt haben es
ist vor allem natürlich auch die
abhängigkeit der deutschen wirtschaft
vom export die wir in den letzten jahren
aber immer mehr gesteigert haben also
sag mal deutschland war immer ein ex
export starkes land aber es ist eben
etwas anderes ob unternehmen exportieren
das sind ja die hidden champion sie
einfach ein weltmarkt brauchen weil sie
in der nische produzieren da reicht der
nationale markt nicht erreicht der
europäische nicht oder ob ein land wie
deutschland inzwischen fleisch
exportiert weil wir teilweise so
schlechte löhne haben dass sich das
rentiert und das ist einfach völliger
irrsinn
das heißt wir brauchen natürlich auch
wieder eine stärkere binnenmarkt
orientierung eine starke kaufkraft der
menschen weil dann entsteht hier in
diesem land auch mehr
und dann kann man sich zumindest etwas
völlig ab unabhängig vom export wärme
nicht werden aber zumindest etwas eine
gegenkraft aufbauen hier im land
nachfrage und da ist zum beispiel ein
infrastrukturprogramm natürlich ein ganz
wichtiger faktor wenn wir dieses land
auf vordermann bringen wenn wir die
abgehängten regionen endlich mit
infrastruktur versorgung mit
öffentlichen dienstleistungen dann ist
das nicht nur im nebeneffekt sondern in
einem ganz wichtigen effekt natürlich
auch ein konjunkturprogramm das würde
auch tatsächlich
dazu führen dass diese krisen tendenzen
zumindest deutlich abgemildert würden
bau haben wir gegenwärtig eben keine
rezession sondern wir haben es
beispielsweise im anlagenbau also die
maschinen auf der welt die wir
exportieren und aber ich bin bei den
investitionen sogar bei ihnen also damit
gar keinen dissens gab der einzige
unterschied ist bei ihnen sind die
öffentlichen investitionen oft ein grund
warum man sagt die reichen oder die
großen unternehmen müssen geschröpft
werden sein gutes recht bei mir ist es
andere argument hat so und ich sage wir
müssen investitionen frei setzt indem
wir im haushalt spielräume nutzen und
vielleicht auch kreativer mit den
möglichkeiten umgehen ich nenne ein
beispiel
der staat hält anteile an der telekom
und der post
das sind längst privatisierte
unternehmen an der commerzbank ist der
staat beteiligt was will der staat mit
aktien von der commerzbank frage ich sie
mal da reingegangen ist ich war wegen
der bankenkrise ja weil die banker
banker versagt haben ja wieder die
allgemeine zeitung und das sollten wir
verbieten die bankenrettung ich hätte
damals übrigens alle banken
verstaatlicht und nicht nur die
commerzbank alle verstaatlichen und aus
allen gleichzeitig raus aber es setzt
thema der vergangenheit und sie haben
das damals nicht sehr laut gevor doch
total also aktien telekom post
privatisieren und das geld nicht in den
staatshaushalt sondern da könnte man
eine rieseninvestition strong machen für
startup-unternehmen glasfaser in
ländlichen regionen von thüringen und so
weiter und so fort spannender punkt noch
mal zum schluss eher kurze
abschlussfrage wir haben auch heute
immer wieder darüber gesprochen was
können wir alle selbst ändern was muss
vielleicht die gesellschaft ändern
haben sie persönlich irgendwas geändert
jetzt in den letzten monaten fliegen sie
weniger machen sie irgendwas anderes um
das klima zu schützen
also natürlich muss man sich bei allem
was man tut fragen ob das sinnvoll ist
aber ich finde einfach diesen
privatisierten ansatz nicht so wichtig
nicht richtig weil der ist schon ein
privilegierter ansatz also klar kann ich
als jemand der bundestags ab die epen
hat sagen okay ich verzichte jetzt auf
die urlaubsreise oder ich verzichte
darauf aber wenn man das zum generellen
sozusagen maßstab macht es gibt viele
menschen in diesem land die machen eine
urlaubsreise im jahr und die ist eben
per flug und das finde ich sollten sie
auch weiter tun können ohne dass man da
hat die debatte sie selbst so
beschäftigt dass das sie selber es
geändert haben
im alltag also ich würde schon drüber
nachdenken wenn ich hier zum beispiel
irgendwo hinfahre ist das jetzt nötig da
mit dem auto hin zu fahren kann man das
anders machen
oder ich muss zugeben persönlich privat
mache ich eigentlich fast nie flugreisen
aber das hat etwas damit zu tun dass ich
einfach den jetlag nicht mag
also das ist auch eine persönliche
präferenz aber ich hätte freilich eine
falsche debatte vor allem darüber zu
reden weil es ist eine debatte
unterprivilegierten es ist nicht eine
debatte für die breite sachen und auch
größere sachen die man die man ändern
kann man nicht nur mit geld zu tun aber
gibt es bei ihnen was ja also ich
schickt voraus ich will nicht verzichten
ich will auch nicht dass andere
verzichten müssen
ich will durch technik erreichen dass
die menschen frei leben sich frei
bewegen können in einem konkreten fall
ich hab jetzt für für meine fahrten hier
in berlin ein wasserstoffauto statt
eines verbrennungsmotors mit fossilem
treibstoff und das kommt übrigens aus
deutscher produktion dieses auto vielen
dank für die eindrücke zum schluss
vielen dank für die angeregte diskussion
heute sahra wagenknecht christian
lindner vielen dank ihnen beiden vielen
dank für ihr interesse
heute und auch in den vergangenen jahren
für mich war es das letzte mal in diesem
platz wir sehen uns an anderer stelle
wieder morgen sind die kollegen der
phoenix runde hier für sie ich wünsche
ihnen einen schönen abend das war unter
den linden wie immer für eine besser
informierte republik
[Applaus]
[Musik]